well we knew they couldn't keep Bosco
out of it for long whatever that's how
many episodes yes what a massive amount
of stuff they'd given him to do you want
to totally start a war yeah I'm totally
down for that hey don't do that yes sir
but I might do a voice again if I'm Zuko
may or may not be a live Fire Lord
guy I feel like that they dropped the
hint about that I say but but hey my
grandfather's been friends with the
avatar
and he sounds exactly like me Oh be
careful see was still has the same point
that would be fascinating but anyway
this is peacekeepers this is way I
thought we were watching Adventure Time
what were you watching you know I seen
so many episodes maybe there's you know
having such a weird effect on me maybe
he's trying to look like Korra I don't
know
oh but yeah so this is peacekeepers it's
sort of like a oh I can describe how
like an in-between episode just kind of
getting stuff set up for probably the
next episode or maybe the episode after
that and nothing nothing major happens
until the end and even the major stuff
is cast stuff we know is not going to
last
oh no a spirit a quorum oh no they're
really broken up you know I believe it
see how everyone's been acting it's
probably the best thing honestly
obviously a dysfunctional relationship
macho does something that makes sense
she hurls his desk across his office
well and the interesting thing about
this episode is all the stuff being
suggested is cool but clearly insane and
everyone seems to be along for it and
again so I'm an interesting crowd except
for Marco the only voice of reason in
the entire yeah no it's one of those
things where it's like well okay it's
you have everyone wants to do this
really batshit crazy idea like
everyone's fucking on board with it just
like hey you know the
doesn't support us fine we'll take this
girl that's like hope it'd be like
movies constitutional authority yeah
comedy oh it's is that against but at
the same time like when I was so talking
about you know the plan that they're
gonna do it's like this sounds pretty
cool I got ready and it's like oh yeah
responsible adults I though there was a
part of me that was just like well for
God's sakes a general in the army would
be yeah that sounds like a great idea
Cora the only thing I can figure is like
cuz he's like digit and he says it out
loud so if my fleet was to accidentally
bump into the Northern Water Tribes Bach
aide then in theory we would only be
defending ourselves so basically I'm
gonna go start a war because the
sixteen-year-old teenage girl told me to
but it's yeah who's clearly showing
she's quite crazy a MIDI scene so yeah
it's what everyone seems to be on board
with it excel you say except for maximum
I like Marco had the exact same reaction
I had when they came up with it eases
like when Bolin's telling him it he's
like and then we're gonna go to general
Iroh who's then gonna bump into him and
start a warrior Marcos is like that
seems like a terrible
yeah it's but but it's an awesome idea
so it's like okay you have logical
common sense but then you have awesome
as kicking possibilities so and it's a
viewer I want to kick your pots of
building and somebody's like yeah it's a
rider I'm like I'm just like yes so I'm
really very torn on that so it's I it
makes Cora look I'll give credit that at
least everyone is in on the stupid crazy
plan and not just course it makes her
look a little better but at the same
time it's like everybody said not this
stupid crazy plan okay I'll tell you
what bothered me Korra's plan is dumb
but you're right everybody it was in on
it I think the part where I start to
losers where Marco is legitimately
figuring out that there's a conspiracy
and she's just always biting his head
off like seriously and then like when
she finally like kicked his desk
I just watching it for the first time
I'm just like she's just one step
removed from a thug now he's like I'm
not happy like and it is old that's not
me getting old it's pretty I mean she
gets swallowed by the spirit at the end
so I'm hoping maybe going into the
spirits belly or whatever's gonna knock
some sense into her she'll have some
spiritual journey worship realize
something which I thought we kind of did
already at the end of season one when
she hit her lowest low apparently wasn't
her lowest low because now she's like
running around trying to start slow so I
don't know yeah I've been trying to
defend this show as best I can but I'm
finally hitting a point now where I'm
just like I'm having issues and I'm like
I I don't know what to say anymore I'm
getting like to assert it doesn't get
tiring because I can't yeah I don't know
how to defend it really except to say
like well maybe she's gonna learn from
this with the same time like I just said
I thought that's what season one was
about yeah and it seems to be like I
don't know it's on I say if we already
know what she's supposed to learn and we
do we know she's supposed to learn
patience and being smart and not rushing
into things and again we had sort of the
first season for that that's our ahead
issue with but you give it a pass the
fact that just doing it again is just so
tiring and not furthering anything well
I guess my thing is after five six
however many episodes were in I'm not
seeing any learning actually that's one
thing I'm like maybe if she came to some
sort of conclusion somewhere but it's
just like be subtle what'd she do she
threatens a judge with her manbearpig
you know we can't afford to start a war
well I'm gonna ride with this protest
even lin beifong's like yeah that's
really gonna keep him calm you know
Mako's like you know hey maybe it's
ignored fuck you Marco like yeah
this is like I'm gonna break his desk
I'm going to charge her off on a
motorboat and I'm like I'm not seeing
any growth yet maybe I'm getting it to
that point where I'm just like okay
you've done what you can with she's an
angsty teenager now we need to spit I
mean like you said they did they did in
the first season our way why are they
just but I I will say this again all the
other side character stuff was great
whatever he comes to tents in with the
lemurs like I was like I met you a
little bit more interested in this okay
yeah this is my biggest issue is how how
tired is the main story getting when I'm
like the coolest things in this episode
was maca and Tenzin and his boy training
flying lemurs I'm like by all accounts
this would be the dull side story of the
you know is shown I'm like let's see
what's going home Philippe yeah no it's
like it's it's like it that's the only
legitimate emotional moment in this one
is that it let me get quick I don't like
really hate this episode honestly you
know I'm not like that angry at it but
this emotion axe this was the only
emotional moment in this was when the
boy says it's tough being the Alpha
lemur intense and says I know it's like
you get it and you feel it and that
there is a problem when you realized
that you felt real emotion there and yet
the scene were the main love interests
breakup it's like hey that guy fell
right whatever and and would you get
swallowed by a giant spirit it's like
and we don't you get out of it volume so
whatever I don't know if I hate this
episode but this was the first episode
I've seen all season or I'm like I feel
kind of taxed now like my patience is
starting to wear thin like I'm like is
you know I was saying in the last I'm
like oh I'm psyched let's see where they
go with this and then I'm just like I
came out of this like that whole scene
with General IRA I'm like sweet you know
I wasn't know what's gonna add that
nothing it was like okay there were four
lines and okay well what's gonna happen
with this clever or nothing well they're
not gonna get the president well they're
not gonna start the war well they break
up what you said was like yeah that felt
like just what it needed to be I mean on
tenzin side we got this promise of
Oh Tenzin's kid sees the Statue glowing
and all of this and I'm still kind of
sitting here like oh yeah what was that
what was that like we still haven't gone
back to that and while the the training
of the lemur scene I thought was
actually pretty cool I'm still kind of
like you know it when it's all said and
done he's training some lemurs there's
nothing really earth-shattering there
well not and what I what I'm realizing
watching is Judas the scene was and the
best line in there was what he says
being the Alpha lemur is lonely and he's
like I know yeah you know it's like oh I
was like where are they going with this
and when it got too bad I'm like I get
it okay well played that was awesome and
what I'm realizing at you serve a
difference between this one the next one
and again maybe it's building up to
something but with the first season that
I did realize that for all the faults I
guess or I have with it
I did want to know what was gonna happen
with the name main story I wanted to
know what's gonna happen with this ahman
guy who he was I'm trying to remember
what actually like is the main concern
it's some sort of civil war was it again
about getting spirits sort of put away
they're coming yeah what was sort of the
thing we've got the civil war brewing
yeah it's kind of like what's the main
urgent oh no let's get back this is this
woman's not marriage yeah like that I
like yeah yeah well what's the main
focus that really has our concern maybe
that's why the tents and stories are so
much better and have us because you
immediately get the concern you
immediately know there Ares come they're
short they're sweet they're intimate
they're like really small stories and as
good as I thought because I actually
like the first season and we're not done
with this so I mean they may be pulling
something really cool up ahead I'm
really hoping I go into the spirits of
that yeah yeah I mean we were promised
the spirit world I feel like we're like
okay well this five episodes in we're
still a political thriller but the the
first season I thought it was a really
really good political thriller and I
thought it was really tightly written
some of the I still think the bending
fall or winter
let's go you know I've been involved
that's fine you're a hundred percent
wrong but that's completely fine but at
the very least you want to see what's
gonna happen okay that's so I don't like
you know I came away to go back to the
political thriller I felt that was the
thing I want to duplicate I'm it's like
I don't like bending ball fine but
whatever but it still was all tied
together and in that 13 episodes I'm
like okay you crammed one really good
story and that involved two villains you
know their backstory all of this you had
and I wanted was gonna happen and it
kept the fool don't have a villain
villain I don't know what Locke's deal
is yeah he's just sort of a kind of sort
of want power my brother yeah we knew
that music oh we knew the the Fire Lord
the Fire Lord was like Sauron his never
saw him but he was like this presence I
think that was one thing like in I will
totally admit cuz like we sound like a
couple of douche bags here just like I
will say okay straight up we are
armchair quarterbacking because sort of
only six and five you know we only like
you know a handful of episodes in so I
mean this is totally armchair
quarterbacking and like the show could
totally pick up and be like way better
than season one ever was and this was
just like you know the just getting
there so no I I think there is a problem
I guess I because I think both of us had
the same reaction that we cared more
about the tents and story about trying
train the lemur and had an actual
legitimate emotional moment even if it
was all would be suppose everything it's
like yeah orbing these lessons I'm not
getting it even though I liked it I
liked this other story fine I love these
side characters like Oh side characters
much more here than I did the last one I
love the Sailor ass
Mako's investigation was the most
interesting in this episode to me like
ooh who is this guy yeah why is the Fire
Nation perhaps in on this who hired you
that I'm like I'm like that's kind of
interesting like and then but even that
I had an issue with that because the two
very obvious corrupt cops it's like the
Springfield Police Department go
phone it in low like okay yeah let me
throw the picture in the but here's my
thing though it's like things are not
adding up for me it's like Lin beifong
was such a badass you know the cops seem
to have everything under control and now
Mach o is here and I'm just like so you
got these two corrupt cops that don't do
jack shit and when beifong the first
thing she says is well give it to those
two and I'm like huh
yeah like I thought Lin was like a
little more savvy than that I guess I
don't want to see her kind of like
running an idiot department or like so I
don't know but I think overall for all
the armchair quarterbacking and this is
just an armchair quarterback observation
watching this season unfold so far it
seems to me in this may be because of
the way negotiations when the collodion
went down they didn't know where they
may have been going with this all of
that was up in there but it seems to me
like this went backwards I feel like a
mon and that whole plot thread with the
republic unwinding and all of that and
the battle versus the benders and Korra
finding and hitting their lowest low
should been after all this and I know
this may completely reverse itself and I
will totally eat my words any like now
this worked out but so far just so far
into this I'm just like that was an
instantly connectable villain that like
I feel like that was really upping the
ante and so I feel like we're kind of
just basic you where it is instant in
that if you you could say in a sentence
sort of what the plot of each season of
you know the avatars I like last season
you know well as the plot stop a guy who
wanted to take away bending from benders
it's like you get it and hey that's not
good it gets a little more complicated
interesting but here it's like what's
the plot um spear world blowing up that
somehow equals Civil War would be it's
you can't explain it in one sentence no
way don't you two terribly if that's
wondering why I'm wondering if it
wouldn't have been better than to start
off with that plot thread because season
one of the original avatar and I
of it that tends to be a little more
fillory kind of or figuring this out as
we go kind of season then maybe they
would have been better served if they
went with this story arc first yeah even
as simple enemy Amman because am on that
whole concept to me as I was like that's
about this ultimate as it gets to take
away the bending to have a villain with
the spirit world they can force you
though it can I just haven't seen you
haven't seen a really dabble with yet
you know yeah even with the original
avatar as simple as it is fire Lord
wants to destroy world or takeover world
if you get it and you get the investment
it's like I'm not seeing the real
investment here it's like a war can
start on between these people you saw
don't know in these people you also saw
I don't know but you can know these are
main characters are from there kinda so
it's okay and but but then the spirit
world which we don't really know that
well its own stuff and stuff we don't
really know that well we know the
characters are invested which is great
but we're not bad invested and another
thing I don't get is what is the purpose
of the Republic because I'm getting very
confused it is like well we got to go to
the president and is like you know the
president you know they have their photo
hobbies like okay you gotta intervene
the two water tribes are just like going
in it's like well it's not the
Republic's place to really I'm like what
you're called the United Republic what
are you fucking doing what is their
purpose I'm like I mean I don't get is
are the other nations still in existence
and the Republic is a separate entity
like a sort of Model UN or something was
it maybe middle and that sort of thing
yeah I just don't get what their point
is maybe Korra has a point when she say
what's wrong with you get in there sort
of thing but at this or maybe not cuz
it's like hey you kind of need to know
what you're getting into as well so but
you're I'm kind of dealing it's like you
know I would just look into it whatever
and it doesn't seem like they're doing
much so maybe maybe I start the point
the episode man makes a little bit more
like hey what's the right thing well I
think white has a point I just thought
their solution which is to like you know
hey I got an idea let's wipe our ass
with the Republic's Constitution until
they start a war with the army I'm like
that's a frickin coop yeah
okay whatever so Mike that's
insurrection and general Iroh is like
Raqqa I've tried yeah so so I guess
bottom line the because both as a writer
and a viewer we're not totally blown
away with this episode because we don't
get our die are the Cold War and we
don't really have much logic to feel
like thank you like fuckin okay I want
my wallet or just something but I don't
think this is like the worst episode
we're gonna jump the shark but yeah but
it's sort of like yeah I definitely
don't we're gonna good places and yeah
let's really get a focus here that we
can get behind you know end a story that
we can say very simply this is it can
have complications right but the story
very simple that we can say yes I want
to get behind this I want see what's
gonna happen next week you know like I
say even with the first core of season
the problems I had I would still tune in
because it's like way well what's gonna
happen what's gonna you know I wanna
know what's gonna happen with this bill
and everything here it's like maybe the
spirit world but even then that's not
really dealt with much so I don't have I
mean I'll keep tuning in I mean I guess
I do so I'll see what happens because
it's these people you know the same
people good core in Avatar but it's more
just I'm tuning in for that and maybe
see some of the fun side characters all
I know
no there's no investment of I have to
see this and that's kind of a shame yeah
cuz I can say with the first season I
seriously was like every single episode
like I just would like one seem that
someone like right away it was just like
watching one after another and I was
completely hooked after this episode and
that's the thing is so far I've been
really trying to defend this show and
like no no I don't get good it's it's
you know we're doing pretty good I like
all these things this is the first
episode out of the set that I'm just
kind of like yeah that was
oh yeah okay so what I'll watch the next
one hoping it's better yeah so I mean
it's get the spirit world I think that's
a big because I'm going to explain to me
how the Republic works cuz I just I
don't get it I mean they may be as
inefficient as the UN but I'm like I
thought you all were the Republic I
thought it's the United Republic why
does the Republic then they have a
military if it's not comprised of the
four nations which means it has to be
compel the four people can come in and
steal it under their noses
I mean unless it's like the United
Nations but but in which case can they
march him and take over the water - it's
so many constitutional issues yes
so forget all this still good side
characters um still good side stories
honestly as comedy was still great yeah
let's get it all not to talk yeah I
thought the whole Nando thing we see the
costume it's great oh so yeah hopefully
hopefully we'll get some some spirit
shit going on it is called spirits omit
may will finally see a few so until then